so Qatar or Qatar we debated which one
it depends I hear on cable news all the
time they pronounce it every which way
Qatar or Qatar I say Qatar use a cutter
the put that country over there so
they're getting the World Cup in 2022
that's what it sounds like at least at
the moment now a lot of people are
fighting against that there's all kinds
of reasons because it's gonna be hot as
hell there they're also funding a lot of
Terror all over the Middle East and the
world some big problems there but then
an interesting piece came out in The
Guardian that they basically are using
slave labor from North Korea
pretty much indentured servants to build
the actual stadium so we've got some
more info for you according to the
testimonies from workers laborers said
that they receive almost no salaries in
person during the three years that they
typically spend there so they're sending
people from North Korea they spent three
years basically getting okay the
expectation is that they will collect
their earnings when they return to North
Korea but workers receive as little as
ten percent of their salaries when they
go home and some may receive nothing at
all the workers essentially are there to
earn foreign currency for North Korea
this is this is pretty terrible stuff
and you know all these things when we
have Olympics in different places in
World Cup and all that we hear all this
stuff about all these people literally
getting killed there's been many many
people that have already been killed
while building this thing they have no
rights and protections and anything like
that
does this surprise you in any way like I
feel like people just don't really care
about this stuff because it always
happens for a North Korean to look
around and go this is some slave labour
[ __ ] it's gotta be pretty friggin
bad you know it's gotta be pretty bad
doesn't surprise me
I could show I saw you nodding along
this definitely doesn't surprise you
yeah being a dick doesn't surprise I
don't think anyone at this point but you
know this is actually a Qatar issue like
and an international community issue
anyone who's the World Cup fan like this
is an instance where we actually
probably have some power in the
situation to really shine a spotlight on
the authorities in Qatar so hard that
they can't hide from it and they it but
they actually have to address it right
now what could what could we actually do
well there's you know they mentioned an
organization in that article I think
it's the
antislavery and distillery international
they're like 175 year or year old
organization that's working on shining
that spotlight and just through social
media through support of those
organizations that are pushing forward
anti-slavery efforts we can we can
potentially ensure that they're no
longer enslaved in Qatar we can't really
do anything about the North Korean
slavery but right at least their home is
the bigger problem here that people just
love these events so no matter what
happens you know we there have been
stories even this past summer about that
in Brazil people were getting displaced
and they were just removing all these
low-income houses they were just
literally just making people homeless to
build the stadium and to build
concession stands like there's something
about sports and this national pride
thing that it supersedes any kind of
human right thing right it's a terrible
thing and I think any country that
treats their women as second-class
citizens it's no surprise that they're
gonna treat foreigners as second-class
citizens which they do but I also think
it becomes a fine line of here we are
having so much aggression towards the
Middle East as some of it warranted some
of it and maybe not but but we have a
situation where we can involve them into
a world organization in a world pastime
and I and so it's a hard thing to say
do we not go there now at all or do we
take the good with the bad and say you
know what we want them to participate
because you can't just keep pushing
those kind of countries to the side they
have to participate and maybe part of
the party participation also comes with
people standing up from the other
countries like the United States and
like England and saying you have to take
some responsibility for what is going on
here yeah so I mentioned that all the
time every time we talk about gay rights
and that's that part of the world every
time we talk about women's rights in
that part of the world all all basically
human rights minority rights all that
they really have none of that in that
part of the world and yet we still grant
them the ability to host these things
women in Saudi Arabia still can't drive
now it sounds like maybe they'll be able
to drive to vote like it's just such a
mess so what are we supposed to do
Alysha I mean I think that by
potentially hosting the World Cup here
it's putting them on the net on the
international stage right and it's
giving other countries an opportunity to
learn more about this country on the
other side of the world that they may
have no idea about to travel there in
some cases and I think that it's only
through that sort of interconnectivity
that you can even sort of begin to
address some of these inequality issues
and by you know by meeting these people
by learning more of their customs or
just learning more in general yeah I'm
sort of Pro doing more of the sort of
development stuff in in those countries
yeah I like the idea I just don't know I
mean look at Russia like we gave them
the Olympics and then it looks like
things got a hell of a lot worse or at
least the core at least according to the
people in Crimea I suppose I think what
should happen is people that actually
going to go to that event should bring
their wives and their rowdy cousins that
are chicks and just get their drink on
and everything show the women there look
what we got